ora ne vorrei mettere oltre a quelle
americane una italiana che odio e forse
una dei pochi telefilm che si sarà una
delle poche fiction che si salva e
distretto di polizia
allora non è che mi piaccia proprio da
impazzire però è una delle poche sedi
che ha una storia un filone continuo
dietro le ogni singola puntata perché
molti telefilm hanno puntate tutte
separati che non c'entrano niente una
con l'altra invece almeno fino alla
quinta fino mi sembra quinta o sesta
serie quando se ne va via la pandolfi e
muoiono e ricky memphis e giorgio
tirabassi se ne vanno via
poi diventa uno schifo di sedi politiche
finali era veramente bellissima
e italiana cioè le scene d'azione sono
un po un po squallido e anche un pelo
vecchio e distretto di polizia però le
storie erano belle erano piene gli
intrighi pieni di misteri che quello che
serve per i telefilm secondo dei misteri
che ti spingono ad andare avanti per
guardarlo per guardarlo per sapere con
chi è l'assassino per sapere i misteri
gli intrighi eccetera per questo non mi
piacciono le altre fiction italiani per
esempio i cesaroni
un ciclone in famiglia anche se sono
divertenti diciamo sono le fiction per
tutta la famiglia però bucks discostiamo
di aste con
carabinieri un modo ma puoi fare una
fiction come carabinieri burqa miserie
poi se l'è carabinieri 7 carabinieri 8
ma così tanto ma siete fuori di testa
guardarlo perché i teli del film
continuano in base agli ascolti non mano
c'è qua continua sei sette otto stagioni
carabinieri fa proprio schifo ma proprio
schifo ecc e le le le puntate di
distretto di polizia sono serie le scene
d'azione sono un po squallide dei
carabinieri le le storie sono
squallidissimi e le generazioni
ma proprio toccato il fondo ma proprio a
raschiano per terra uno schifo
eccolo li volevo parlarne dopo dei
telefilm squali l'uomo è scappato va
bene e io o paura di lasciare indietro
qualche serie che non mi viene in mente
qualche si ribella che non mi viene in
mente va bene allora passo alla mia
serie per eccellenza cela la serie
televisiva con la s la t maiuscola
proprio e the lost è già qui
che fa schifo che non capite nulla
maledetti lost e il telefilm per
eccellenza e di lo se non vi posso dire
nulla perché la storia non me la posso
raccontare se non stare qui quattro ore
purtroppo su youtube di quattro ore non
posso metterli sono veramente vi giuro
che racconterei tutto farei le mie
teorie eccetera eccetera eccetera perché
come lost non c'è niente
grandissimi attori grandissimi
personaggi storia incredibile poi c'è la
gente che guarda una puntata che ne so
fa e va bene allora lobont se mi dici
che bello lo guardo guardano una puntata
che ne stanno trasmettendo per esempio
la terza serie allora guarda una puntata
della terza serie falsi ma io non ci ho
capito nulla e type e credo che non hai
capito nulla che con lost non puoi
andare piano piano per questo è brutto
guardarselo in tv perché in tv negli
aspri jaguar di due puntate a settimana
una o due puntate a settimana e non
capisci nulla veramente ti dimentichi
tutto quello che succede sempre invece
bisognerebbe prendersela comprarseli
diciamo tutte tutte tutte le stagioni
finora trasmesse e spararsi lim
aggiornano in una giornata no però
bisogna spalar sele tutti insieme senza
con pochissime pause sennò i
collegamenti salto e non si capisce bene
più perché di collegamenti c'è adesso
nella quinta serie riprendono cose che
sono successe nella prima ne nasconde
nella terza nella quarta quindi
bisogna fare attenzione
poi è l'uni è uno dei pochissimi
telefilm forse un altro telefilm che ha
fatto così è stato hicks file che ti fa
uscire dal telefilm che tu quando è
finito telefilm diciamo che è lì che
inizia la vera esperienza di lost
inizia a prendere appunti veramente una
cosa allucinate inizia a prendere
appunti scrivi le tue teorie su il
perché sono finiti gli sui collegamenti
vai rivederti vecchie puntate per vedere
ah sì avevo ragione era quel personaggio
mii pazzesco veramente pazzesco in
creatori sono dei geni puri ora vorrei
fare la classifica dei c
migliori cliffhanger chissà cos'è un
cliffhanger il cliffhanger sono i finali
di stagione
in realtà non sono solo i finali di
stagione ci sono le puntate che
finiscono con un mistero oa metano
cioè quando finiscono a metà che succede
qualcosa ma non la fanno finire perché
finita la puntata quelle opi feng e
teoricamente i migliori cliffhanger sono
a fine stagione c'è l'ultima puntata
della stagione finisce lì che testa di
lì
e mo e e mo devi aspettare l'anno
prossimo allora prima di iniziare a
classifica vi dico una cosa spoiler lo
cioè vuol dire racconto il finale
quindi se non so se voi non avete visto
quel finale ancora estate seguendo
telefilm ma non siete arrivate ancora
quel punto mi raccomando bloccate io
prima di dirvi la posizione in
classifica mi fermo un attimo e vi dico
bloccate saltate quel pezzo se non
l'avete ancora visto mi raccomando non
voglio rovinarmi non in quinta posizione
ci metto senza ombra di dubbio the
shield la stagione 5 il finale della
stagione 5 quindi se non l'avete ancora
visto bloccate mi raccomando
wow c'è in quel pezzo muore uno della
squadra di
del protagonista tra forme ricordino me
perché l'ho visto due anni fa
uno della squadra del protagonista per
mano dell'amico perché lui credeva una
cosa invece era un'altra allora lo
chiama per parlare per parlare per
chiarirsi solo che lui non vuole
chiarire ha già in mente la sua idea
sganciano laguna granata e la mette in
nell'auto di lem si chiama questo qua di
lem esplode c'è ma una scena tremenda
perché se tutti sei affezionato i
personaggi sai che non sono amici per la
pelle la squadra d'assalto sono amici
per la pelle e vedi questa scena
veramente piangi sarà il libro della
fiom dello zucchero visto quarta
posizione
24 il finale della prima stagione
se non l'avete visto bloccate
allora premetto una cosa io di 24 ho
visto solo le prime tre stagioni e io so
che i migliori finale diciamo alla
migliore stagione in assoluto è la
quinta quindi pian piano ci arriverò io
mi baso sulle prime tre stagioni e
secondo è il finale della prima è
bellissimo bellissimo in senso diciamo
negativo perché
tutta la prima serie lui lavora diciamo
fa tutto quel casino per liberare la
moglie la figlia e alla e alla fine alla
moglie e muore gli sparano in muore lui
tutta la prima serie passa a cercarla e
quando la trova muore a trovarci non me
l'aspettavo veramente non me l'aspettavo
sono rimasto male in terza posizione
metto qui è stata dura perché ho dovuto
nelle prime tre posizioni lo scambiate
le ho messe perché era un po di deciso
comunque di al terza posizione metto
prison break la seconda stagione prima
non ho messo prison break mi son
dimenticato anche prison break è un
telefilm assolutamente da vedere adesso
è finito anche questo mi sembra con un
film a me manca ancora la quarta
stagione da vedere comunque per ora e
bellissime geniale veramente tutto di
intelletto questo telefilm perché il
protagonista è un genio bella storia la
sappiamo tutti
sono due fratelli uno in prigione lui fa
fa finta di fare una rapina diciamo fa
una rapina per farsi arrestare per farsi
mettere nella stessa prigione del
fratello per farlo fuggire e questo è
solo l'inizio e cioè dopo succede un
casino della misera con e quindi uno dei
cliffhanger più belli e il finale della
seconda stagione di prison break se non
l'avete ancora visto boccate cosa
succede che ritorna in prigione c'è
nella prima nella prima stagione fugge
nella seconda c'è nella prima stagione
fugge dalla prigione nella seconda fugge
per le città perché sono ricercati
ovviamente nella terza ritorna in
prigione c'è lui non ce la fa più in una
prigione tremenda schifosissimo è di
nuovo diciamo si ricomincia in meglio
però perché la terza stagione veramente
bella e che dire geniale
seconda posizione molto combattuta con
la prima dottor house
il finale della quinta stagione se non
l'avete ancora visto e sono sicuro che
molti non hanno vista perché la quinta
stagione metà la stanno dando ad esso in
tv quindi
buoni non ascoltate se non l'avete
ancora vista devo dire una cosa tutti i
cliffhanger dalla prima alla l'ultima
serie a la quinta sono atroci nel senso
buono c'è veramente ti corrodono al
fegato quando li vedi perché se li mangi
tutte le dita
e questo questo finale di stagione della
quinta stagione questa è stato hanno
combattuto molto con quello della quarta
la doppia puntata quando si ammala la
ragazza di di wilson il migliore amico
di dottor house e non si sa perché a usa
e senza memoria si ritrova coinvolto in
un incidente di un pullman ma non si
ricorda per che quindi deve vi diciamo
riprendere la memoria si scoprono delle
cose atroci nella quinta stagione per
gli show è il cliffhanger della quinta
stagione non inizia nell'ultima puntata
ma inizia quattro cinque puntate prima
con le visioni e tutto il resto occhio
che se non l'avete ancora vista dire o
meno tutto visioni della propria della
ragazza che è morta nella quarta
stagione alla fidanzata di wilson
visione causate probabilmente dal
vicodin alla medicina che si prende
finisce in un istituto mentale alla fine
c'è a un multi l'ultima puntata è tutta
una vita bellissima non voglio neanche
raccontarvela anche se l'avete già vista
riguarda the rack e vela riguardo pulire
allucinante
e il primo posto sta ovviamente sì come
lost e il mio telefilm preferito la
terza stagione di lost se non l'avete
ancora vista mi raccomando perché questo
è uno dei finali di stagione che mi ha
fatto rimanere tv un quarto d'ora 22
o molto con da
si scopre che si salvano si scopre che
si salvano che vanno via dall'isola con
una frase sola se tu non perché fosse
impostato con i flashback cesa ci sono i
momenti sull'isola e poi i flashback dei
prendili ogni singolo protagonisti si fa
vedere qualcosa i collegamenti con altri
personaggi eccetera nell'ultima puntata
della terza stagione ti fregano gli
autori di pesi che quello che si vede di
jack che uno dei protagonisti siano
flashback invece no è il flash forward
c'è una cosa che è successa nel futuro
dopo l'isola infatti alla fine lui parla
con kate sano stanno parlando lui con la
barba non si sa come mai si voleva
suicidare
gli urla mentre lei va via con la
macchina
dobbiamo tornare sull'isola dobbiamo
tornare sull'isola e prima poco prima
gli dice questa frase da quei capisci
tutto da lì mi è caduta la mascella per
terra e rotolata fuori dalla finestra
gli ha detto